hey Laura what are we doing this evening
so you've got a bunch of printouts
cardboard tube glue we've got wire we've
got Dowling Dowling Dremel tools markers
illustrator make into the foam core and
going back
it should be okay we got lots of fun
court so we have four main pieces of the
head cottonmouth
the edges now in order to get the head
Square two of the pieces the two side
pieces are actually slimmer and then
seen in the front back okay yes so what
I'm gonna do is I'm actually going to
assemble it in two different corners but
I'm not gonna join them yet because I
still need to cut the eyes out of the
face and also the mechanism for the neck
is going to need to be more work more
work start gluing these and then start
building the back okay so the pieces of
the head are drying you're assembling
the neck mechanism now so old foldy
works well he was really all he was was
a post with a head on top and a mouth
that flapped a new Foley is going to
work basically like a upside down
marionette so we have a so this will be
my control thing and I'll hold this and
there'll be four posts coming off of it
that will go up into the head and then
moving this will cause the post to move
but now they're on it on a dual axle
it'll make a lot more sense once it's
assembled and invisible but but yeah so
that's that's how he's going to
ultimately work and then there will be
another control for the
awesome it's almost functional so I've
just got to finish wrapping this post
and then attach one more post and we can
hopefully see it in action
hopefully have it work as its supposed
to
all right fingers crossed he's crossed
okay how are we doing then I am very
excited this is going to be difficult to
learn to use but as you can see we now
have a working thing so it needs to be
stabilized a little bit and I need to
work on these axles down here but as you
can see we have side-to-side motion and
his head as well
there we go so alright the neck
mechanism was built and the two halves
of the head are drying and we're going
to a party catch y'all after
bacon either this bacon
what's also got their candied bacon me
look like beef jerky but it's fine
well there's still a lot of fine-tuning
to do with it but
we now have a neck the mechanism fully
in place the sides are sealed the
electronics are now inside and are
working and so we're just in the process
of hack sawing out the piece of
plexiglass that will turn into the rest
of the eyes all right taking the plexi
and we've scuffed it with the wire brush
I think it probably needs a bit more
scuffing but
not too bad
I'm gonna play I can do this while
holding the camera not tip him over the
LEDs are now mounted on a board which
gives him proper pupils build the job
built the jaw controls and and he'll be
ready to go
hey everyone this looks so I am back
you